[Musique]
pour notre grand entretien notre invité
aujourd'hui suit au plus près les
négociations de la crise en ukraine
puisqu'il est le président du conseil
européen le belge charles michel est
toujours chargée d'accorder les violons
des 27 ce n'est pas toujours facile
bonjour monsieur le président vous
d'ailleurs vous entretenez régulièrement
avec vladimir poutine
qui a déclaré que l'opération militaire
russe en ukraine est un succès le
président russe vladimir poutine à a su
se sur est une nouvelle fois ne pas
avoir l'intention d'occuper l'ukraine
qu'est-ce qu'il veut exactement alors
mais c'est en tout cas par un succès
c'était un désastre d'abord pour
l'ukraine bien entendu avec le des
destructions massives des civils qui
sont visés je pense est aussi un
désastre pour la russie parce que d'une
part la résistance ukrainienne prend
très clairement par surprise l'armé de
la lumière poutine et la fermeté des
sanctions européennes supporté par nos
ali prend aussi de cours le régime
politique et une mytho kremlin mais les
européens ont décidé en effet d'un
quatrième train de sanctions financières
mais ils ont en quelque sorte aussi
reconnu qu'il n'était pas en mesure de
décréter un embargo sur le pétrole et le
gaz dont lieu dépend le pour ce qui est
du gaz à 40% ça promet encore des débats
très animés entre l'allemagne qui refuse
cet embargo la pologne et les pays
baltes qui eux le souhaitent et ses
essais au prochain sommet des 24 et 25
mars
ce qui est certain c'est qu'on a été ta
pas le très rapidement d'être très uni
et très ferme sur les quatre premiers
paquets de sanctions qui sont
extrêmement puissants et impactant les
sanctions visent près de 700 personnes
individuellement y compris la lumière
poutine sergueï lavrov les sanctions
visent une 71-70 entité surtout des
entreprises d'état et on a encore
renforcé les dernières heures et les
derniers jours et resserré l'impact de
ces sanctions s'agissant du gaz et du
pétrole je verrai tout à fait clair
quand on s'est réuni à paris on a tous
considérés
toutes les options devaient être
envisagée sans tabou il est certain que
les premiers paquets de sanctions qui
ont été décidés vise à affecter le
kremlin pour essayer d'infléchir la
position du kremlin tout en limitant les
impacts négatifs pour l'union européenne
mais nous suivons la situation de
manière permanente de manière régulière
on aura encore l'occasion dans les
prochains jours d'un sommet européen à
bruxelles avec la participation de john
dryden donc on est dans la coordination
permanente et nous sommes prêts chaque
fois que ce sera nécessaire à prendre
les décisions qui s'imposent mais
justement certains disent qu'on n'est
plus prêt à aller au delà vers un
cinquième ronde de sanctions parce que
finalement ça nous offre rétro est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec cette idée
mais c'est certain c'est que c'est dans
l'unité pourra prendre des décisions sur
ce sujet et c'est certain ce qu'on va
pas mener ces débats là sur la place
publique vous savez qu'on admire poutine
décide de cibler par des bombardements
telle ou telle ville en ukraine telle ou
telle cible en ukraine il nous informe
pas à l'avancé je pense le succès du
point de vue européen de la réaction qui
a été très forte elle a été aussi lié à
cette capacité de prendre le kremlin par
surprise il ne fait aucun doute que le
kremlin ne s'attendait pas à une telle
résistance militaire en ukraine le très
bien ne s'attendait pas à la capacité de
l'union européenne de mobiliser jusqu'à
un milliard d'euros d'ores et déjà pour
de l'équipement militaire y compris les
talles le kremlin ne s'attendait pas à
l'unité transatlantique et sur tous ces
sujets là en prenant le kremlin par
surprise on montre d'une part au monde
entier que l'armée russe n'a pas la
puissance que peut-être le kremlin
imaginez on voit bien les faiblesses
logistique par exemple de l'armée russe
et on voit aussi la force politique de
l'union européenne on voit bien que le
marché intérieur et la capacité de
décider des sanctions économiques et
financières
ce n'est pas un détail c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement puissant
extrêmement impactant et s'agissant du
gaz et du pétrole il légitime que cette
question soit posée mais il appartiendra
aux 27 chefs d'état et de gouvernement
en permanence comme nous l'avons fait
depuis trois semaines maintenant de
faire l'analyse de la situation et de
voir quelles sont les actions que nous
db non afin afin d'avoir un impact
positif et d'influencé
un autre rapport de force entre
l'ukraine et la russie qui sont en
pourparlers comme vous le savez pour
tenter d'obtenir un cessez le feu voir
pour tenter d'engager un processus de
paix l'ukraine a rejeté justement
mercredi l'idée d'un modèle autrichien
ou sous les doigts de neutralité
présenté juste avant par moscou comme
finalement un compromis ce statut neutre
obligerait le cren à ne pas rejoindre en
quelque sorte l'otan est ce que cette
proposition vous paraissait acceptable
est ce que vous estimez que l'ukraine à
raison de refuser
alors c'est certain c'est un premier
élément c'est que ce sont les ukrainiens
et c'est le gouvernement de vladimir et
les sites doit décider en souveraineté
en indépendance quelles sont les
positions de négociation de l'ukraine sa
première éléments et nous venons nous en
soutien de l'ukraine deuxième élément
nous comprenons bien été question des
garanties de sécurité est fondamental
pour les ukrainiens on va bien sûr les
ukrainiens sont victimes d'une guerre
sauvage qui a été déclenchée par
vladimir poutine qu'il est normal que
les ukrainiens soit très mobilisés pour
protéger leurs intérêts en termes de
sécurité et ça veut dire que l'union
européenne aura aussi un rôle essentiel
à jouer parce qu'on a bien que c'est la
sécurité du continent européen qui est
en discussion c'est un exemple pour
illustrer le propos le bélarus sous
pression russe probablement a décidé de
changer sa constitution pour permettre à
terme le déploiement d'armes nucléaires
ça n'est pas neutre il est légitime que
en ukraine on s'inquiète de cette
situation et que l'on souhaite que ce
type de questions puissent aussi faire
l'objet de discussions si un processus
de paix réelle devrait démarrer à un
moment donné
les etats unis s'engagent vous l'avait
dit pour un milliard de dollars de
matériel militaire notamment de défense
antiaérienne et nous les européens 1
milliard d'euros mais c'est vrai que les
armes restent difficiles à acheminer les
avions sont d'ailleurs tabou et c'est un
problème disent les creuses ukrainien
pour faire face aux raids aériens on
n'en fait pas assez de ce côté là
d'abord c'est certain c'est que l union
européenne après une décision immédiate
extrêmement forte puisque pour la
première fois dans l'histoire union
européenne nous livrons du matériel
terre létale et nous allons continuer à
le faire pour situer à versailles il
était décidé d'augmenter de 500 millions
d'euros cette capacité et ça vient en
addition le seul les états membres
fournit également comme moyens
militaires aux jeunes évidemment pas
commenté les manières dont on peut
délivrer ce métal de manière
opérationnelle il ya un autre débat qui
était un débat pour le temps plus que
pour l'union européenne c'est le débat
soit no fly zone d'interdiction de
survol du territoire ukrainien et dont
on comprend bien la difficulté moi je
comprends parfaitement la légitimité de
l'appel du président ukrainien vers les
partenaires les les amis de l'ukraine et
en même temps je comprends bien qu'à
l'otan pour l'instant en tout cas la
décision a été prise de ne pas aller
dans cette direction parce que ce que
nous souhaitons c'est stopper les
hostilités savoir négocie à un processus
de négociations de paix et nous voulons
éviter le risque de l'escaladé ou de
l'aggravation de ce conflit qui
impliquerait le temps on mesure bien que
ce débat est un débat qui est
extrêmement compliqué et je suis
totalement convaincu pour la
continuation de très très près comment
on peut aller au maximum du soutien en
ce compris par du matériel militaire aux
verts les ukrainiens pour qu'ils
puissent continuer à résister sans poser
un acte qui sans qu'on ne le voudrait
amen aggravation du conflit avec un
risque de troisième guerre mondiale la
cour internationale de justice plus haut
tribunal de l'onu a ordonné à la russie
de suspendre ses opérations militaires
il ya aussi le président joe biden qui
qualifie poutine de criminels de guerre
et il y aura effectivement vous l'avais
dit à bruxelles la semaine prochaine un
sommet otan est ce que on va relancer
l'alliance atlantique au contraire il
faut plus de défense européenne
l'un va avec l'autre si nous voulons
prendre notre destin en main comme
européen doit effectivement renforcer
les capacités sur le plan de la défense
européenne et si l'europe de la défense
est plus forte et plus efficace et plus
performante ce sera bon pour le temps ce
sera bon pour l'enfant de nos ali et
pour l'ensemble de nos partenaires et
c'est peut-être ça le changement que
l'opéra ni siens qui a lieu à versailles
met en scène la déclaration de
versailles est un pas en avant
spectaculaire
pour l'intégration européenne y compris
sur le terrain de la défense puisque
nous disons on va renforcer
structurellement des capacités
européennes en matière de défense en
faisant le lien avec la base
industrielle dans le domaine spatial
dans le domaine du cyber par exemple et
on va faire ça en lien avec cette
ambition de continuer à consolider cette
alliance transatlantique
c'est évidemment tout à fait essentiel
on voit bien que les menaces dont on
parlait depuis longtemps qu'il devait
amener à mr ce débat soit rétabli
quelques temps déjà elles ne sont pas
théoriques et ne sont pas virtuels sont
bien réels avec toute la souffrance ça
signifie pour le peuple ukrainien qui
est en première ligne aujourd'hui pour
défense en fait leur territoire leur
enfant mais aussi pour défendre des
valeurs qui sont celles de l'union
européenne mardi dernier les premiers
ministres polonais de chèques et
slovènes ainsi que jaroslav kaczinsky le
président du pis le parti au pouvoir en
pologne se sont rendus à kiev pour
réaffirmer leur soutien au premier
ministre et président ukrainien vous
démentez tout mandat du conseil européen
ils sont allés de leur plein gré c'était
peut-être pas une bonne idée d'ailleurs
moi je soutiens toutes et tous les tous
les ans tous les messages tous les actes
de soutien à l'ukraine et au
gouvernement ukrainien sa première
éléments et nous étions effectivement
informé la première commission et moi
même consulté sur le sujet on peut pas
parler aux strictement d'un mandat
partial mandat supposerait qu'il ait eu
un débat au conseil d'européens qui
engagerait les vingt-sept leader ce
passé dont il s'agit mais il est plutôt
bien que des leaders européens des
premiers ministres en l'occurrence aille
à kiev pour exprimer et était à quai
pour exprimer la position du conseil
européen la position de l'union
européenne
certains disent que justement mais plus
du tout la pression ni sur la pologne ni
sur la hongrie sur la question de ces
droits de l'homme intérieur maintenant
qu'ils sont sous une crise une
canadienne qui prend toute la place avec
l'accueil des réfugiés en urgence
moi j'ai vraiment confiance dans le
travail qui est mené par la commission
européenne pour résoudre ce sujet là si
nous souhaitons effectivement à l'issue
du débat que nous avons eu sur le plan
de relance européen c'est mettre en
place un mécanisme qui garantie l'état
de droit qui garantit ses principes tout
à fait fondamentaux et on sait qu'il y a
des discussions entre le gouvernement
polonais et la commission européenne
et c'est bon tu sais ces discussions se
poursuivent
merci monsieur le président du conseil
européen charles michel en direct avec
nous deux en duplex plus exactement
depuis bruxelles le consilium
merci à vous de nous avoir sur 6 sur
france 24
[Musique]